bonjour Sarah et l'airi bonjour la
journée nationale de la laïcité est-ce
qu'il y a des tabous à l'école entre
l'histoire la religion la jeunesse et
les réseaux sociaux le service national
universel et puis cette affaire aussi de
professeur de danse écartées à Sciences
Po la suite de plaintes entre guillemets
d'étudiant c'est donc la journée
nationale de la laïcité aujourd'hui 9
décembre une question est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment de l'autocensure des
professeurs en cours sur les questions
de religion et de laïcité vous savez
aujourd'hui c'est une journée qui compte
énormément parce qu'effectivement sa
journée de la laïcité mais ça devrait
être toute l'année c'est tellement
essentiel dans notre dans notre pays que
ça devrait être célébré protégé défendu
tous les jours maintenant pour répondre
à votre question il y a du tabou et de
l'autocensure partout et donc l'école
n'y échappa de fait et là faut se poser
pourquoi en fait il y a de l'autocensure
mais dans la discussion à la table en
famille dans l'entreprise à l'école dans
des assos mais parce que la laïcité
pendant longtemps on a considéré que
c'était un acquis qu'il fallait plus
l'expliquer résultat
et bien nous n'avons pas suffisamment
défendu on l'a pas on n'a pas tenu tous
ces maillons de la chaîne et donc
aujourd'hui s'il y a réponse ça doit
être une réponse plus globale moi mon
job avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale c'est de donner les outils aux
enseignants d'être protégés réellement
avec le soutien fonctionnel par la loi
par comment préciser mon parce que
certains professeurs quand même ne se
sentent pas suffisamment soutenu un bon
souvient de ce qui est arrivé à Samuel
Paty bien sûr mais depuis il y en a qui
ont renoncé parfois donc comment les
aider heureusement c'est le début de la
fin je le dis comme je le pense par
contre déjà la première des choses c'est
pas de poussière sous le tapis ça veut
dire quand il y a des situations il faut
les déclarer et donc dire quand il a des
problèmes de être formé parce que vous
savez le nombre d'enseignants qui disent
mais je sais même pas par quel boulot
prendre la laïcité pour les jeunes
aujourd'hui c'est un truc un peu vieux
un peu parfois ringard qui fait que
priver de liberté et qui vient
[Musique]
quel est elle mais comment comment agir
quand je la laïcité ça doit être tous
les jours
off
IVe est consommateur passif et bien de
ses offensives qu'on voit sur les
réseaux sociaux qui te disent allez
bouscule les règles mais par exemple un
voile à l'intérieur ou encore d'autres
mais des signes mais des signes
religieux mais au contraire la côte en
fossive elle doit être elle doit
permettre de créer du contenu numérique
en particulier avec le soutien du cipdr
qui dépend et qui est porté par ma
collègue Sonia bac S et donc c'est une
sorte de jeu en concert ministre de
l'éducation nationale ministre de
l'Intérieur mini de la citoyenneté
ministre des associations
qui donnent les moyens aux jeunes même
de rendre la laïcité moderne
contemporaine
il va y avoir des contenus de votre part
c'est simple de votre part ont fait dans
quelques dans quelques minutes après
notre interview je vais aller dans un
lycée le lycée de Diderot où il y a la
fête de la laïcité aujourd'hui ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il faut du
support artistique culturel du débat
posez les choses ça veut dire que c'est
des jeunes qui vont débat de la laïcité
faire de la musique autour
[Musique]
parce que c'est des vidéos du
gouvernement ils vont prendre ça comme
la propagande quoi bien sûr qu'on fera
évidemment des vidéos du gouvernement
direct et on le fait déjà mais on va
l'amplifier ce qui est nécessaire c'est
que les jeunes eux-mêmes en réalité
créent leur propre support je veux dire
une chose très simple quand je discute
avec un jeune je me rends compte parfois
malheureusement qui considère que c'est
dépassé la laïcité alors je vais sur son
terrain de manière assez simple moi j'en
ai marre d'entendre dire que la laïcité
elle réduit des libertés et donc je dis
quoi laïcité c'est quoi dans le fond
c'est ce qui protège le fait de pas
avoir de différence entre les femmes et
les hommes aujourd'hui on a une
génération qui est hyper attachée à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et là quand tu lui dis pourquoi à ton
avis des femmes iraniennes arrachent
leur voile au prix de leur vie parce que
il se trouve que en Iran il y a la loi
de Dieu qui porte et qui pèse plus que
la loi et bien qui reconnaît l'égalité
et puis tu vas plus loin pourquoi
aujourd'hui en Chine les wigours sont
fondamentalement et bien bousculer
oppressé par le régime chinois c'est
encore pour des raisons professionnelles
et donc là tu te dis mais la laïcité
c'est exactement l'inverse c'est ce qui
permet à chacun qu'il croit qu'il ne
croit pas de pas avoir et jugé par
rapport à ce prisme là ça c'est mon job
c'est de faire que ça redevienne en
réalité et bien le fruit le le en
réalité le quotidien protégé bon très
bien on comprend le bien-fondé de ce que
vous voulez défendre Sarah Larry sur la
laïcité mais d'une façon très concrète
comment vous faites face au contenu sur
l'ensemble en fait de ces plateformes
qui mettent en évidence en fait des
tenues religieuses qui incite en fait
des gamins allez avec ces tenues
religieuses à l'école la commande bien
sûr j'ai convoqué Tik Tok avec mon
homologue et mon collègue Jean-Noël
Barrault qui en plus pour le coup
offensif on leur a demandé deux choses
un de virer les les vidéos avec de la
géolocalisation dire que quand une vidéo
elle est faite en France et elle appelle
en réalité bousculé les lois françaises
ils ont la capacité de le faire et je
vous assure qu'on les suit à la culotte
pour être clair et puis il y a aussi une
offensive qui est portée nous avec les
enseignants et avec des capacités à
signaler et donc on crée du contre du
contenu contre-fensif et c'est là où
j'ai besoin de la mobilisation de tous
pour gagner ce combat
qui pourrait s'en charger est-ce qu'il y
a une instance en charge de ça
aujourd'hui moi j'ai aujourd'hui il y a
des offensives il y a des instances bien
sûr on peut engager la responsabilité
des uns et des autres mais là le guide
mais sur d'autres d'autres sujets
au-delà de la diffusion de vidéo et donc
la question c'est comment les
signalements sont plus rapides et plus
effectifs il y a Tik Tok snapchat
twitter facebook en fonction de ses
algorithmes il y a comment dire il y a
des des différences d'appréciation moi
ce que je veux c'est que on sort de que
c'est chipouille en réalité et que quand
une vidéo est crée du trouble dans notre
pays ou essaye de fragiliser quête
français alors on la bloque le service
national universel vous en êtes en
charge il y a l'idée de le rendre
obligatoire pour les jeunes ça va venir
ou pas ça soyons très clair le service
national c'est d'abord c'est d'abord une
aventure qui permet aux jeunes de se
rencontrer de vivre un temps où on
célèbre la France on lève un drapeau on
fait du sport on crée de la mixité
sociale où il y a le goût aussi d'une
certaine manière de l'effort collectif
on quitte son département pour la
première fois c'est presque 60 000
jeunes qui l'ont fait depuis on est un
moment aussi où et bien il y a plusieurs
hypothèses qui sont qui sont sur la
table on fait des retours d'expérience
et le président de la République aura
l'occasion de revenir sur les
conclusions du service national
universel et donc ces évolutions futures
bah écoutez dans les prochaines semaines
prochain mois en janvier en février le
service national universel va devenir
obligatoire ce que je suis pour les
jeunes
c'est qu'il y a des hypothèses qui sont
étudiées nous sommes en train de faire
un état des lieux et un bilan et de fait
par contre on se dirige plutôt vers ça
ou pas ce qui est certain une indication
c'est que aujourd'hui les inscriptions
du service national sont ouvertes et
tous les auditeurs que ça intéresse
parce que c'est des jeunes de 15 à 17
ans moi je les invite à aller sur
smu.gouv.fr et de regarder ce que c'est
parce que dans le fond allié engagement
sport un peu de patriotisme d'une
certaine manière responsabilité
individuelle et goût de l'effort
aujourd'hui ça s'appelle le service
national universel et c'est encore trop
peu connu à mon goût et ce qui est
certain c'est que les parents et les
jeunes adorent vous vous y êtes
favorable pour le rendre obligatoire
Sarah et là il fait plutôt ah non mais
quand on vous entend mets-moi la mission
que m'a donné le présent de la
République est très clair il m'a dit
avec le ministre des Armées Sébastien
lecornuu et avec le mix de l'éducation
nationale papaye tu as tu as comme
mission de créer le plein déploiement et
la généralisation c'est ce que je suis
en train de faire avec plusieurs
hypothèses la gratuité de préservatif
pour les 18 25 ans en pharmacie l'année
prochaine des 1er janvier pourquoi parce
que c'est absolument essentiel pour les
jeunes de se protéger de rappeler que à
peine quelques jours on se rappelait à
quel point le sida avait fait des
ravages aujourd'hui on est en train de
voter en train d'inscrire dans la
Constitution le chemin a commencé le
droit à l'IVG les protections
menstruelles sont une vraie avancée la
précarité des jeunes est-elle parfois
malheureusement que les protéger et leur
donner accès c'est une avancée en
réalité progressister social énorme donc
moi je suis extrêmement heureuse que mon
gouvernement par la voix du président de
la République rend le préservatif
gratuit à l'attention des jeunes juste
simplement en allant à la pharmacie
alors qu'il y a le retour du covid
beaucoup évidemment n'ont pas forcément
parce qu'ils ont déjà été touchés
contaminés quels sont vos
recommandations voilà que le ministre de
la santé va se prononcer cet après-midi
sur le port du masque potentiellement
dans les transports on a vécu ensemble
une période assez dingue de vraiment
avec les confinements aujourd'hui il y a
les fêtes de Noël je crois on aime tous
nos familles
le plus simple et le plus judicieux en
tout cas c'est la liberté de le faire
mais si on aime les gens on le fait on
va à la pharmacie on dit qu'on va voir
son grand-père sa grand-mère ou ses
parents et que ils sont peut-être
âgés et donc pour eux ce vacciner c'est
aussi des protéger il faut rappeler que
il y a quand même un pic à nouveau qui
arrive on a de plus en plus de
contamination le port du masque dans les
transports en commun franchement c'est
important c'est pour se protéger et
surtout c'est pour éviter d'être tout
seul d'être tout seul pendant Noël et de
faire
la transmission peut se faire malgré
tout même si même si cependant ça
protège cependant
quand on les aime on vous donne tous les
moyens bon après chacun est libre de
faire comme il veut mais collectivement
on peut faire que dans de ne pas vivre
déjà tout seul le Noël ou la fin d'année
et le vivre ensemble genre ça nous a
tellement manqué que ce serait dommage
de ne pas participer à l'effort
collectif vous êtes en charge donc de la
jeunesse et du service national
universel on vient d'en parler il y a
cette histoire cette professeur de un
Sciences Po Paris qui a été écarté parce
que pour des propos jugés sexistes et
discriminantes parce que grosso modo
elle voulait dire homme et femme et pas
leader follower qu'est-ce que que vous
inspire cette histoire moi j'aime bien
quand on parle en français déjà parce
que c'est ce qu'elle a dit elle-même en
français donc à mes femmes je sais ce
que c'est leader followers alors
j'arrive à j'arrive à deviner mais pour
être plus clair j'ai pas les tenants et
les aboutissants de de cette histoire à
Sciences Po je suis comme vous j'ai lu
deux trois articles de presse nous nous
avions tout à l'heure Valérie là en
question qui a été écarté j'ai vu en
venant sur votre plateau une réaction de
sciences pollue lui-même donc je vais
pas m'exprimer sur ce cas particulier
par contre ce qui est certain c'est que
moi ce que je combats c'est exactement
l'idéologie qui terrorise les gens qui
veulent nommer les choses donc tout ce
bolly-boulga qui nous vient des
États-Unis du modèle anglo-saxon qui qui
fait que on a une génération qui va être
d'une susceptibilité folle ce n'est pas
bon il faut pouvoir nommer les choses
être en en désaccord débattre bien sûr
mais ne pas poser cette une sorte de
terreur moralisatrice quel que soit le
bonisme en quelque sorte quoi c'est ça
en fait partie c'est une c'est une des
formes d'expression moi je crois que il
faut montrer c'est mon combat est un
combat anti raciste et anti
discrimination nommé une femme un homme
bah ce n'est pas en réalité stigmatisé
personne c'est pour autant quand il y a
une situation discriminante et bien
c'est tout un pays qui se lève que ce
soit homophobe transsophobe raciste
antisémite peu importe ça c'est le
modèle universaliste par contre aller
faire la allez créer finalement du doute
de la peur ou dans le fond de la censure
à certains égards c'est dangereux bon
sang et c'est exactement l'idéologie que
je combat merci Sarah et Larry
secrétaire d'État en charge de la
jeunesse et du service national
universel qui